since we've been talking about how stars
form and the evolution of stars i
thought it was about time that we looked
at some cool pictures of stars forming
or stars themselves or evolution of
stars so this right here is from the
eagle nebula eagle i should capitalize
the e
this right here is from the eagle
the eagle nebula and just so you know
the word nebula is kind of a general
word for any interstellar cloud of gas
or dust so when we're talking about the
eagle nebula we're talking about a huge
nebula and it's actually it's a it's a
nebula that spans and just so you have a
sense this is just one of the pillars
in the this is called the pillars of
creation you've probably seen this image
before there's these three pillars here
and this is just a small part of the
actual eagle nebula and just this pillar
right over here
just this pillar here just so that you
have a sense of how large it is
how large it is just this pillar itself
is seven
light years
it is seven light years tall so this is
an enormous amount of distance remember
the distance from earth to the nearest
star was about four light years it would
take voyager if it was pointed in the
right direction at moving at sixty
thousand kilometers per hour it would
take voyager 80 000 years to go four
light years just this pillar is seven
light years but i wanted to show you
this because these type of nebulae as
the plural of nebula
are where stars can form so this right
here you actually see this is actually a
kind of a breeding ground for the birth
of new stars this gas is condensing just
like we talked about a couple of videos
ago until it gets to that critical
temperature that critical density where
you can actually get fusion where you
could actually get fusion of hydrogen so
this is just a huge interstellar cloud
of hydrogen gas and over here you could
say well you could just see it's just
this just this breeding ground four
stars and we don't even we actually
think that this structure doesn't even
exist anymore because remember this
thing is very very far away from us in
fact it is just so you have the number
this is 7 000 light years away
7 000 light
light years
away which means that what what we are
seeing now the photons that are reaching
us right now reaching our eyes or
reaching our telescopes right now left
this region of space 7 000 years ago so
we're seeing it as it was 7 000 years
ago so a lot of this gas a lot of this
hydrogen may have already condensed into
many many many more stars so this
structure might not be the way it looks
right now and actually there was another
supernova that happened that we think
might have kind of blown away a lot of
this dust and we won't even be able to
see what the effects of that supernova
were for another thousand years but
anyway this is just a pretty amazing
photograph in my opinion especially and
it's beautiful at any scale but it's
even more mind-blowing when you think
that this is seven this is a structure
that is seven
light years tall and this is really just
part of the eagle nebula one of the
pillars of creation
this right here is a star field and this
is as we're looking towards the center
of our galaxy the milky way so this is
the sagittarius star field and what i
just want you
the neat thing here is you just see such
a diversity in stars and this is also
kind of mind-numbing because every one
of these stars are inside of our galaxy
this is looking towards the center of
our galaxy we're not looking at this
isn't one of those where we're looking
beyond our galaxy or we're looking at
clusters of galaxies this is just stars
here but see here you see a huge variety
you see some stars that are shining red
right over here and obviously the
apparent size you cannot completely tell
because the stars are at different
distances and at different intensities
but the the redder stars these are stars
at their red giant phase
or they're probably at their red giant
phase i haven't done specific research
on these stars but that's what we
suspect those are the red giant phase
the ones that are kind of in the
yellowish white part of the spectrum
these are stars probably in their main
sequence probably not too different than
our own sun the ones that are in the
yellowish white or closer to orange
yellowish white part of the spectrum and
the ones that look a little bit more
bluish the ones that look a little bit
more bluish or a little bit more
greenish these are burning super fast
let me see if i can find this one looks
a little bit bluish to me
these are burning sorry i had to pause
the video for a cough these are burning
super super fast and so the the super
massive stars they burn kind of fast and
furious and then just die out while the
smaller the smaller stars the ones with
less mass they burn slower over many
many over a much much much longer period
of time so the ones that are burning
really fast are meeting a lot of energy
at the at the
the smaller wavelength part of the light
spectrum and that's why they look bluer
or greener and these are going to be
more massive stars the ones that look
wider or bluer greener while the redder
ones the redder ones are are are less
massive stars that are in kind of their
super giant phase and so they are at
this point cooler than kind of the main
sequence stars
this right here
this right here is the cat's eye nebula
and the word nebula this is actually a
planetary nebula and i want to
differentiate this right here is a
planetary
this is a planetary nebula
and
it's you it's called a nebula because it
is kind of this gas that's that's kind
of floating out in space but it's at a
completely different scale than this
nebula than the eagle nebula that we
drew over here so normally when people
just talk about nebulae they're talking
about something like the eagle nebu this
huge masses of interstellar gas when
people talk about planetary nebula this
is still actually a huge huge radius but
nowhere near seven light years but it's
still a huge but this is the byproduct
of a star shedding off all of its outer
material so this is at the center of
this we see a fairly mature star here
and it's shed off kind of its outer
layers and it did that while it was in
this red giant phase so the core would
keep flaring up keep having these hot
explosions and every now every time you
had one of those hot explosions you had
more and more of its outer layers
getting pushed off
pushed off into space forming this
planetary nebula so this as we see it
right now it's still not yet a white
dwarf it is still an active star fusion
is still occurring in the star but it's
well on its way to becoming a white
dwarf it once all the fuel runs out so
it's past the red giant phase it's
thrown all of this material into space
and it's on its way to becoming a white
dwarf anyway hopefully you enjoyed that
i actually find all of these all of
these images to be pretty captivating
especially the star field one because
this is just inside of our galaxy so
hopefully it gives even more
appreciation for how many stars there
are i mean this is just a small fraction
of the 200 to 400 billion stars inside
the milky way